luego de la reunión tripartita entre el
Primer Ministro de Armenia el presidente
de azerbaiyán y el presidente del
Consejo europeo que tuvo lugar en
Bruselas el pasado 14 de mayo el
representante europeo emitió un
comunicado en el cual afirmó que tanto
Armenia como azerbaiyán reconocen su
integridad territorial la duda de la
sociedad Armenia a partir de esta
declaración era así los
86.600 kilómetros cuadrados de
azerbaiyán incluyen el territorio de
nahorno carabajo hoy finalmente el
Primer Ministro de Armenia Nicole afirmó
que nahorno caravag formaría parte de
azerbaiyán y además agregó que la
cuestión de derechos y seguridades de
los habitantes tengamos en cuenta que
más de 120.000 armenios Residen este
territorio actualmente deben ser
discutidos directamente por
representantes de nagorno carabaj y bakú
esto generó disconformidad en vasto
sectores de la sociedad de Armenia y
especialmente en los residentes de
naborno caravaj quienes se encuentran en
un bloqueo desde hace más de seis meses
cuando azerbaiyán decidió cortar el
corredor versor lachín que une al
territorio de naborno caravaj con
Armenia